This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Religions tell us they have the key to our best lives. Advice columnists tell us how to solve problems in our relationships. And airport bookstores are stuffed with tomes on how to grow rich, manage our time better, and build effective habits. All these sources of counsel can teach us valuable skills such as planning, patience, and perseverance. These can be vitally important to success. But in a world overflowing with useful advice, why do so many people feel stuck?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。宗教告诉我们，他们掌握着我们过上最好生活的钥匙。建议专栏作家告诉我们如何解决人际关系中的问题。机场书店里塞满了关于如何致富、更好地管理时间以及养成有效习惯的书籍。所有这些建议来源都能教会我们宝贵的技能，例如计划、耐心和毅力。这些对于成功至关重要。但是，在一个充斥着有用建议的世界里，为什么这么多人感到迷茫？
One answer, many of us are pursuing goals that are misaligned with our own deepest values and preferences. This week, in the latest installment of our Wellness 2.0 series, what psychology can teach us about choosing a meaningful path for our lives. When you're a kid, grown-ups ask you what you want to do when you're an adult. When you're a teenager, college counselors ask you what you want to study. Once you join the workforce, managers ask you what your goals are for the next few years. At every stage, we are really being asked the same question. What do you want to do with your life? At the University of Missouri, psychologist Ken Sheldon studies the science of knowing what to want, how to set your sights on targets that will actually make you happy if you achieve them. Ken Sheldon, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hey, I'm happy to be here. I want to take you back to 1981, Ken. You just finished
一个答案是，我们许多人追求的目标与我们内心深处真正的价值观和偏好并不一致。本周，在我们“健康 2.0”系列的最新一期节目中，我们将探讨心理学能教会我们如何为生活选择一条有意义的道路。当你还是个孩子时，大人们会问你长大后想做什么。当你十几岁时，大学辅导员会问你想学什么。一旦你进入职场，经理们会问你未来几年的目标是什么。在每个阶段，我们其实都被问着同一个问题：你想用你的生活做什么？在密苏里大学，心理学家肯·谢尔顿研究“知道自己想要什么”的科学，研究如何设定那些一旦实现就能真正让你快乐的目标。肯·谢尔顿，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嘿，很高兴来到这里。肯，我想带你回到 1981 年。你刚完成
college and moved to Seattle. You wanted to become a musician. You started a band. How did it go? Rock musicians can be kind of flaky and unreliable and we were all in our 20s and everybody had different goals. Everybody was kind of self-centered and they might not have been committed the way we thought that they were, or maybe the guitarist slept with the singer unexpectedly. There's a lot of things that can just get in the way of having a smoothly functioning unit. We just weren't able to make the agreements and follow through with them that we would
大学学业并搬到了西雅图。你想成为一名音乐家。你组建了一个乐队。进展如何？摇滚乐手可能有点反复无常、不可靠，我们当时都 20 多岁，每个人都有不同的目标。每个人都有点以自我为中心，他们可能不像我们想象的那样投入，或者吉他手可能意外地和歌手睡在了一起。有很多事情会阻碍一个单位顺利运作。我们只是无法达成协议并执行它们，而这些是我们
have needed to make real progress. I understand that at one point you were recording songs for a radio song contest and things didn't quite go smoothly. Yeah, I had recorded my tracks on the song that we were going to submit to this contest. And I left for a weekend hiking trip, expecting that the bandmates would put their tracks down so we could send in the song the next Monday.
实现真正进步所必需的。我听说有一次你在为一场电台歌曲比赛录制歌曲，事情进展得不太顺利。是的，我已经录好了我们要提交给比赛的那首歌的音轨。我出发去进行周末徒步旅行，以为乐队成员会录好他们的音轨，这样我们下周一就能把歌寄出去了。
And I got back and nobody had done anything. It was very disappointing. I remember walking in the rain. It was Seattle, wondering what to do next and coming to the decision that this was probably not going to give me a way to make a living and that music or at least this particular band episode was not going to work out. And that I needed to get serious about maybe something else. What happened to Ken, of course, has happened to millions of people. Maybe it's happening to you right now. You set your heart on something and then find the thing you wanted doesn't look anything like the thing you thought you wanted.
等我回来时，什么都没做。这非常令人失望。我记得走在雨中。那是西雅图，我思考着下一步该做什么，并得出结论：这可能无法让我维持生计，音乐，或者至少是这个特定的乐队插曲，是行不通的。我需要认真考虑做点别的。当然，发生在肯身上的事，也发生在数百万人身上。也许现在就发生在你身上。你全心全意地投入某件事，然后发现你想要的东西和你以为你想要的东西完全不同。
So Ken did what lots of us do. He flailed around looking for something new. He signed up for a master's program. Yeah, it was a program at Seattle University in Existential Phenomenological Psychotherapy. Wow. That's a lot of syllables, but it is a certain tradition within existential philosophy and counseling psychology. It's a legitimate approach to helping people. And I was very interested in that program, not so much because I wanted to become a therapist, but more because I've always just been very theoretically oriented,
所以肯做了我们许多人都会做的事。他四处摸索，寻找新的东西。他报名参加了一个硕士课程。是的，那是西雅图大学的一个存在主义现象学心理治疗项目。哇。音节很多，但它是存在主义哲学和咨询心理学中的一个特定传统。这是一种帮助人们的合法方法。我对那个项目非常感兴趣，与其说是因为我想成为一名治疗师，不如说是因为我一直非常注重理论，
and these were new ideas that I didn't understand that seemed like they might be very relevant to this search for clarity, search for what to do with myself. Again, Ken was doing what lots of us do. We looked at the outside world to give us answers to questions about what we should do with our lives.
而这些是我不理解的新想法，看起来可能与这种寻找清晰度、寻找我该做什么的探索非常相关。同样，肯在做我们许多人都会做的事。我们向外部世界寻求答案，以解决关于我们应该如何生活的问题。
Ken's foray into existential phenomenological psychotherapy was short-lived. The answers he was looking for were not forthcoming. I really enjoyed the year. My fellow classmates, we formed a tight cohort. we did things together. I learned a lot. And the main thing I learned was that I didn't think the answers I was looking for were going to come from that area of knowledge. So what did you do? Well, I once again stopped doing that. I dropped out after the first year and in the end I felt kind of stuck. I was living in Seattle. The jobs I was working were not very well-paying, very high status,
肯对存在主义现象学心理治疗的涉猎是短暂的。他寻找的答案并没有出现。我真的很享受那一年。我的同学们，我们组成了一个紧密的群体。我们一起做事情。我学到了很多。我学到的最主要的事情是，我不认为我寻找的答案会来自那个知识领域。那你做了什么？嗯，我再次停止了那样做。第一年后我就退学了，最后我感到有点迷茫。我住在西雅图。我做的工作薪水不高，地位也不高，
but here I was a Duke graduate. You know, maybe I should be doing better than that. So I was in a sort of period of really, really not knowing what to do next. In addition to not knowing what to do next, Ken felt like he was not measuring up. He sensed the world expected more from him and his impressive college degree. He expected more from himself. He felt lost. Still looking for answers, he signed up for a workshop that was all the rage in the 1970s and early 80s. It was called the Erhard Seminars Training, or EST Training. Yeah, the EST Training was created by Werner Erhard. He's not a spiritual guru. He was
但我毕竟是杜克大学的毕业生。你知道，也许我应该做得更好。所以我处于一个真的、真的不知道下一步该做什么的时期。除了不知道下一步该做什么，肯还觉得自己的表现不尽如人意。他感觉到世界对他和他那令人印象深刻的大学学位寄予了更高的期望。他对自己也有更高的期望。他感到迷失。仍在寻找答案的他报名参加了一个在 20 世纪 70 年代和 80 年代初非常流行的研讨会。它被称为埃哈德研讨会培训，或 EST 培训。是的，EST 培训是由沃纳·埃哈德创建的。他不是精神导师。他
actually a salesman who read a lot about optimal performance and communication and what is the mind and mind training classes. He tried them all and then he created his own version called the Est training and it wasn't a spiritual thing it was actually designed to train you to understand your own mind and to control it better. I understand that at one point you had this training with a 60-hour course spread across two weekends. To describe the course to me, what happened and what you learned and how it ended?
实际上是一个推销员，读了很多关于最佳表现、沟通、什么是思维以及思维训练课程的书。他尝试了所有这些，然后创建了自己的版本，称为 EST 培训。这不是一种精神上的东西，它实际上旨在训练你理解自己的思维并更好地控制它。我听说有一次你参加了这个培训，这是一个跨越两个周末的 60 小时课程。向我描述一下这个课程，发生了什么，你学到了什么，它是如何结束的？
Yeah, well, the way the training was set up, you'd be seated in a ballroom. They'd rent a hotel ballroom and they'd have chairs lined up. And so there would be two or three hundred of you lined up in your chairs. And then the trainer would come out and there would be volunteers who would bring microphones to people to speak into when they wanted to say something. And the trainer led us through a variety of explorations, processes, activities designed to show us how our minds work and how they're currently not working and training us to work them better.
是的，嗯，培训的设置方式是，你坐在宴会厅里。他们会租一个酒店宴会厅，把椅子排成行。所以会有两三百人坐在椅子上排成一排。然后培训师会出来，会有志愿者拿着麦克风给想说话的人。培训师带领我们进行了各种探索、过程和活动，旨在向我们展示我们的思维是如何运作的，它们目前是如何运作不良的，并训练我们更好地运作它们。
I understand the course guaranteed enlightenment at the end of the second weekend? That's right. That was actually the thing that attracted me to it most. I wasn't sure that I needed a self-help training, but that promise of guaranteed enlightenment, I was fascinated to find out what that was going to be. And so what happened the second weekend? Well, so we're on day four, it's Sunday of the second weekend, and it's sort of building and building, and you're getting closer and closer to the material that they really want
我听说该课程保证在第二个周末结束时开悟？没错。那实际上是最吸引我的地方。我不确定我是否需要自我帮助培训，但那个保证开悟的承诺，让我非常着迷，想看看那到底是什么。那么第二个周末发生了什么？嗯，我们到了第四天，是第二个周末的周日，它在不断地积累，你越来越接近他们真正想在最后
to hit you with at the end. And the moment of enlightenment was being told that this is it. You're already enlightened. There's only the present moment. This is it. I imagine this must have been something of a letdown for the 200 people in the hall. Yeah, I mean, it sounds like a bait and switch almost.
向你灌输的内容。而开悟的时刻就是被告知：这就是全部。你已经开悟了。只有当下。这就是全部。我想这对大厅里的 200 人来说一定很失望。是的，我的意思是，这听起来几乎像是一种诱饵和转换。
So after the trainer told us this, people were like, what do you mean this is it? This isn't it. So it's interesting. So in this period of your life, Ken, I think you went through what a lot of young people go through. You know, you've just graduated college, you're trying your hand at different things, you're throwing darts at the wall, nothing's really sticking.
所以培训师告诉我们这一点后，人们就像是，你是什么意思，这就是全部？这不是全部。所以这很有趣。所以，肯，在你人生的这个阶段，我想你经历了很多年轻人都会经历的事情。你知道，你刚大学毕业，你在尝试不同的事情，你在向墙上投掷飞镖，没有什么是真正奏效的。
There must have been a period in your life when it must have felt quite discouraging. Did thoughts of self-doubt go through your mind at this time in your life? Oh, yeah. Yeah, I would say that I've had a lot of self-doubt that I've struggled with. But a big part of the self-doubt involves the knowledge that it's only you who is making the choices in your life. And that's kind of scary. It's all up to me. And I wasn't sure that I was
你生命中一定有一段时间感到非常沮丧。这段时间你脑子里有过自我怀疑的想法吗？哦，是的。是的，我会说我一直在与很多自我怀疑作斗争。但自我怀疑的很大一部分涉及到一个事实，即只有你自己在生活中做出选择。这有点可怕。一切都取决于我。我不确定我是否
good enough to do what maybe I was capable of doing. A drift and uncertain, Ken asked himself what he wanted from life. The band hadn't worked out. The master's program in existential phenomenological psychotherapy turned out to be a bad fit. The EST workshops were a letdown. Ken had always enjoyed science and big ideas. He decided to enroll in a PhD program in psychology. At first, this seemed like another mistake. But several years into the program, a teacher came along who changed the way Ken thought about the question of what he should do with his life.
足够好，能做我可能能够做到的事情。漂泊不定、充满不确定性的肯问自己，他想要从生活中得到什么。乐队没有成功。存在主义现象学心理治疗的硕士课程被证明是不合适的。EST 研讨会令人失望。肯一直喜欢科学和宏大的想法。他决定报名参加心理学博士课程。起初，这似乎是另一个错误。但在该项目中几年后，一位老师出现了，他改变了肯对“他应该如何生活”这个问题的看法。
This wasn't probably till my fourth year that Robert Emmons arrived and I was a little bit adrift up to that point, but once Bob showed up, I recognized that the research he was doing was fascinating and I really wanted to learn about it. And so what he was doing was a new approach to studying personality, where instead of giving people a trait questionnaire, how extroverted are you and how agreeable and so forth, he gave people a blank sheet of paper. And he said, tell me what you're striving to do. And so there'd be 15 blank lines and the participant would write down, you know, 10,
这可能直到我的第四年，罗伯特·埃蒙斯才出现，在那之前我有点漂泊，但当鲍勃出现后，我意识到他正在做的研究非常迷人，我真的很想学习它。所以他正在做的是一种研究人格的新方法，他不是给人们一份特质问卷，问你有多外向、多随和等等，而是给人们一张白纸。他说，告诉我你正在努力做什么。所以会有 15 行空白，参与者会写下，你知道，10、
15, as many as they wanted, things that they are striving to do in their life. And that really intrigued me because it's what I had been trying to do my whole life was figure out what to strive for. Observing how other people write down the things they were striving for gave Ken a crucial insight. Yeah, it is a blank piece of paper and people write things down. And if you think about it, how do we know or how do they know they're writing good stuff down? You know, maybe they're just writing down what their mom told them or their friend told them or
15，尽可能多地写下他们生活中正在努力做的事情。这真的引起了我的兴趣，因为我一生都在尝试做的事情就是弄清楚该为什么而努力。观察其他人写下他们正在努力做的事情，给了肯一个关键的洞察。是的，这是一张白纸，人们写下东西。如果你仔细想想，我们怎么知道或者他们怎么知道他们写的是好东西？你知道，也许他们只是写下了他们妈妈告诉他们的，或者他们的朋友告诉他们的，或者
what society has told them. And so it was only thinking later about, you know, what is the meaning of these goal statements people are giving us that I to wonder, what if they're writing down the wrong things? The hard question Ken realized wasn't figuring out how to get where you were going. It was in figuring out where you wanted to go. When we come back, how to find the answer to that difficult question? When we come back, how to find the answer to that difficult question? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain.
社会告诉他们的。所以，直到后来思考人们给我们的这些目标陈述的含义时，我才开始怀疑，如果他们写错了东西怎么办？肯意识到，难题不在于弄清楚如何到达你要去的地方。而在于弄清楚你想去哪里。当我们回来时，如何找到那个难题的答案？当我们回来时，如何找到那个难题的答案？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Ken Sheldon studies how we choose goals for ourselves. His research has found that we often select the wrong goals. That is, we point ourselves in directions that don't ultimately lead to lasting happiness. An important reason for this error is that people don't have a good sense of what will make them happy. One of the main things we find is that people are not very good at all at knowing how achieving their goals will affect them. They can have a completely off base feeling that this goal, if I finally get it, is going to make all the difference for me. But then when we actually come back and measure their happiness later on to see how it's been affected
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家肯·谢尔顿研究我们如何为自己选择目标。他的研究发现，我们经常选择错误的目标。也就是说，我们指向的方向最终并不会带来持久的幸福。造成这种错误的一个重要原因是，人们并不清楚什么会让他们快乐。我们发现的主要事情之一是，人们根本不擅长知道实现目标会如何影响他们。他们可能会有一种完全错误的预感，认为这个目标，如果我最终实现了，将为我带来一切改变。但当我们后来回来测量他们的幸福感，看看它是否受到影响
or not affected, we often find no change. So one of the biggest reasons that you and others have found that people come up with the wrong goals is that we blindly follow voices in our society that tell us what we ought to want. I want to play you a famous clip from the 1987 movie Wall Street. Michael Douglas plays Gordon Gekko, a wealthy corporate raider
或未受影响时，我们经常发现没有变化。所以，你和其他人发现人们得出错误目标的最大原因之一是，我们盲目地追随社会中告诉我们应该想要什么的声音。我想播放一段 1987 年电影《华尔街》中的著名片段。迈克尔·道格拉斯饰演戈登·盖柯，一位富有的企业掠夺者，
who has some strong views about greed. The point is, ladies and gentlemen, that greed, for lack of a better word, is good. Greed is right. Greed works. So, Ken, today we might say that Gordon Gekko goes too far, but even if we are not willing to be as explicit as this, can you talk about some of the subtler ways in which society tells us that money and power and status are the ultimate barometers of a successful life? Yeah, well, there's many ways.
他对贪婪有一些强烈的看法。重点是，女士们先生们，贪婪，用一个更好的词来说，是好的。贪婪是正确的。贪婪是有效的。所以，肯，今天我们可能会说戈登·盖柯走得太远了，但即使我们不愿意像这样明确，你能谈谈社会告诉我们金钱、权力和地位是成功生活的终极晴雨表的那些更微妙的方式吗？是的，嗯，有很多方式。
We're all immersed in a material consumer culture, which is trying to get us to buy things, click things, make more money so we can acquire status symbols. Not all of us fall for this. It depends a lot on the support and relations and connections that we have. But if you're not sure what to do and so many of these broader cultural messages are telling you to be greedy, you're pretty prone to at least give that a try to see if it works. Yeah, and I suppose another major way that many of us might end up pursuing the wrong things is that we choose goals set for us by other people in our lives. And very often these might be people
我们都沉浸在物质消费文化中，它试图让我们购买东西、点击东西、赚更多的钱，这样我们就可以获得地位象征。并非所有人都上当。这在很大程度上取决于我们拥有的支持、关系和联系。但如果你不确定该做什么，而这么多更广泛的文化信息都在告诉你贪婪，你很容易至少尝试一下，看看它是否有效。是的，我想我们许多人最终追求错误事物的另一个主要方式是，我们选择了生活中其他人为我们设定的目标。而且通常这些可能是
whom we love, you know, our parents, our teachers, our friends, people who say they want the best for us, but people who might not actually know what will make us happy. Do you hear that from your students as well, Ken? Yeah, that's a very common complaint. College students are still trying to figure out what they want, perhaps independently of their parents.
我们爱的人，你知道，我们的父母、老师、朋友，那些说他们想要给我们最好的，但可能实际上并不知道什么会让我们快乐的人。你在你的学生中也听到过这种说法吗，肯？是的，这是一个非常普遍的抱怨。大学生们仍在试图弄清楚他们想要什么，也许是独立于他们的父母。
It's their first real opportunity to get away from their parents and explore on their own. And parents often have very firm ideas about what they want their children to do. And it's not a bad thing. In many cases, they are good ideas, but ultimately, parents are not in even as good a position as we are to experiment and find what we really want. are not in even as good a position as we are to experiment and find what we really want. Parents have goals of their own. They want to acquire the status of having a doctor as a child, and they sometimes can't separate that out from their love and concern for us. So some years ago you were approached by a law professor at Florida State University and Lawrence Krieger wanted to discuss a problem he was seeing among some of his law students.
这是他们摆脱父母并独自探索的第一个真正机会。父母通常对他们想要孩子做什么有非常坚定的想法。这不是一件坏事。在许多情况下，它们是好主意，但最终，父母并不像我们自己那样处于有利地位去尝试并找到我们真正想要的东西。父母有他们自己的目标。他们想要获得拥有一个医生作为孩子的地位，他们有时无法将其与他们对我们的爱和关心分离开来。所以几年前，佛罗里达州立大学的一位法学教授联系了你，劳伦斯·克里格想讨论他在一些法学院学生中看到的一个问题。
What did he tell you, Ken? In his view, in law schools, there's intense competition, there's grading on a curve so that even if you learn almost all the material, you might still only get a C. You're trying to get the prestigious positions. You might end up accepting a job because it's the highest paying, even though once upon a time you might have thought you would have hated doing that type of job. So it can be really confusing for students. And Larry was trying to humanize legal education. I understand the two of you went on to co-author a number of studies involving law students and practicing lawyers. Tell me some of what those studies found. Yeah, we've published several studies. Our first came out in 2004. We were able to track a sample of law students over their entire three-year career
他告诉了你什么，肯？在他看来，在法学院，竞争非常激烈，有曲线评分，所以即使你学会了几乎所有的材料，你可能仍然只能得到一个 C。你试图获得那些享有盛誉的职位。你最终可能会接受一份工作，因为它薪水最高，尽管曾经有一段时间你可能认为你会讨厌做那种工作。所以这对学生来说可能真的很令人困惑。拉里试图使法律教育人性化。我听说你们两人后来合著了许多涉及法学院学生和执业律师的研究。告诉我这些研究发现了一些什么。是的，我们发表了几项研究。我们的第一项研究发表于 2004 年。我们能够追踪一组法学院学生在他们整个三年职业生涯中的情况，
to see what changes occurred in their their well-being and in their mental state. And the first thing we found was something that had been shown before, that their sense of well-being really plummeted quite dramatically and that levels of depression went up quite a bit over the course of the legal career in ways that are more extreme and more concerning than in other professional education. Another thing we found was that there's this paradoxical thing where the students who began with the most idealistic motivation tended to do well. They got good grades in their first year of law school.
看看他们的幸福感和心理状态发生了什么变化。我们发现的第一件事是之前已经显示过的事情，即他们的幸福感确实急剧下降，而且在法律职业生涯中，抑郁水平上升了很多，其程度比其他专业教育更极端、更令人担忧。我们发现的另一件事是，存在一种矛盾的事情，即那些以最理想主义动机开始的学生往往表现良好。他们在法学院的第一年成绩很好。
But that had a sort of corrupting effect where the being the highest graders, they became the highest status students and their values shifted in the direction of looking good, having status instead of helping others. And so their idealistic motivation turned into much more self-centered motivation over time. Here was a set of ideas to explain why people found it hard, why Ken himself had found it hard, to figure out what to do with his life. By the time a person is in their early 20s and is making important decisions about careers and relationships, they've had a good two decades of indoctrination.
但这产生了一种腐蚀作用，因为作为成绩最好的学生，他们成为了地位最高的学生，他们的价值观转向了看起来不错、拥有地位，而不是帮助他人。因此，随着时间的推移，他们的理想主义动机变成了更加以自我为中心的动机。这是一组解释为什么人们觉得困难，为什么肯自己觉得困难，去弄清楚如何生活的原因。当一个人 20 多岁并正在做出关于职业和人际关系的重大决定时，他们已经接受了整整二十年的灌输。
Indoctrination from the culture, which tells them what's worth striving for and what is not. Indoctrination from parents and well-wishers, who have told them what is high status and what is not. And indoctrination from schools, from parents and well-wishers who have told them what is high status and what is not. And indoctrination from schools that often take passion and enthusiasm for a subject and turn it into a race for grades, certificates, and academic honors. The irony is, the better one does at each stage, the harder it becomes to ask if you're
来自文化的灌输，告诉他们什么值得努力，什么不值得。来自父母和祝福者的灌输，他们告诉他们什么是高地位，什么不是。以及来自学校的灌输，来自父母和祝福者，他们告诉他们什么是高地位，什么不是。以及来自学校的灌输，这些学校经常将对学科的热情和热忱变成一场争夺分数、证书和学术荣誉的竞赛。讽刺的是，一个人在每个阶段做得越好，就越难问自己是否
actually doing what it is you want to do. Soon the systems of carrots and sticks that guides us through adolescence and youth is now driving us through our careers. In one study of 6,000 practicing lawyers, Ken found that many of these professionals prioritize things that the world had decided should make them happy,
真的在做你想做的事情。很快，引导我们度过青春期和年轻时代的胡萝卜加大棒系统，现在正在驱动我们的职业生涯。在一项针对 6,000 名执业律师的研究中，肯发现许多这些专业人士优先考虑世界认为应该让他们快乐的事情，
often at the expense of things that actually made them happy. Yeah, we were looking at everything about lawyers that we could think of that might affect their well-being, that most people would think are most important, like how much money do they make, how high status is their job, or did they make partner. But we also included these more psychological variables that we thought would be more important, like do they enjoy and believe in what they're doing? Do they feel like they're making a contribution to the world in what they're doing?
往往是以牺牲那些真正让他们快乐的事情为代价。是的，我们研究了关于律师的一切我们能想到的可能影响他们幸福感的事情，大多数人会认为这些是最重要的，比如他们赚多少钱，他们的工作地位有多高，或者他们是否成为了合伙人。但我们也包括了这些我们认为更重要的心理变量，比如他们是否享受并相信他们正在做的事情？他们是否觉得自己在所做的事情中为世界做出了贡献？
And what we found was that yes, in fact, income correlated with happiness, but it was a pretty small effect, a surprisingly small effect. A much larger effect was their motivation for doing the job. Was it something they wanted to do? They believed in it? They felt like they were contributing to the world by doing it? And that was a much larger determinant of how happy a person they were. So you've said that unhappy lawyers might represent an especially striking example of a widespread phenomenon which is that these people are privileging extrinsic motivations over intrinsic motivations. What do you mean by those terms again? Intrinsic motivation is just doing
我们发现的是，是的，事实上，收入与幸福感相关，但影响很小，小得令人惊讶。一个更大的影响是他们做这份工作的动机。这是他们想做的事情吗？他们相信它吗？他们觉得通过做这件事他们正在为世界做出贡献吗？这才是决定一个人有多快乐的更大因素。所以你说过，不快乐的律师可能代表了一个普遍现象的一个特别显著的例子，即这些人正在将外在动机置于内在动机之上。你再解释一下这些术语是什么意思吗？内在动机就是做
something because you like to do it. It's rewarding, it's interesting, doing it is its own reward. Extrinsic motivation is when you don't really like it, you don't like doing it, but you like what you get from doing it. So you're trying to get a reward from the behavior that'll only come after you're finished. I understand that you have done
某事是因为你喜欢做它。它是有回报的、有趣的，做这件事本身就是回报。外在动机是当你并不真正喜欢它，你不喜欢做它，但你喜欢从做它中得到的东西。所以你试图从行为中获得只有在你完成后才会出现的奖励。我听说你做过
work with Ed Deese who conducted some of the earlier studies into the nature of intrinsic and extrinsic motivation. Tell me about what you did together. Ed was one of the first people to show that not only is intrinsic motivation real, it really matters to be engaged and interested in what you're doing. He also showed that intrinsic motivation is kind of fragile. It can be spoiled pretty easily. He called that the undermining of intrinsic motivation. Ed DC found that these two kinds of motivation had different sources of nourishment. Intrinsic motivation springs up from the inside. It's often shaped by interest and curiosity. Extrinsic motivation comes from the outside. Of course, by the time
与埃德·迪西的工作，他进行了一些关于内在和外在动机本质的早期研究。告诉我你们一起做了什么。埃德是第一批证明内在动机不仅是真实的，而且对于参与和对你正在做的事情感兴趣非常重要的人之一。他还表明，内在动机是脆弱的。它很容易被破坏。他称之为内在动机的削弱。埃德·迪西发现这两种动机有不同的滋养来源。内在动机从内部涌现。它通常由兴趣和好奇心塑造。外在动机来自外部。当然，当
professionals have embarked on a career, they've had 20 or 30 years of carrots and sticks thrown at them by family, by teachers, and by the world. The experiments that EdDC ran show that even when people started doing an activity because of interest and curiosity, adding external rewards and punishments had the paradoxical effect of destroying intrinsic motivation. And so we did these classic experiments showing that when you pay people to do something, it makes them not want to do it anymore. So if you're solving what should be a fun puzzle that almost everybody likes to do,
专业人士开始职业生涯时，他们已经接受了 20 或 30 年家庭、老师和世界扔给他们的胡萝卜加大棒。埃德·迪西进行的实验表明，即使人们最初是因为兴趣和好奇心开始进行某项活动，增加外部奖励和惩罚也会产生破坏内在动机的矛盾效果。所以我们做了这些经典的实验，表明当你付钱给人们做某事时，这会让他们不想再做它了。所以如果你正在解决一个本应是有趣的、几乎每个人都喜欢做的谜题，
but you're doing it because you get a dollar for each correct solution, and then you're left alone in the room for a five minute period, and you can either do more puzzles or you can pick up a magazine. In that condition, you pick up the magazine magazine or today you bring out your cell phone. On the other hand, the participants in his studies who were just told, hey, check out
但你做它是为了每个正确的解决方案能得到一美元，然后你被单独留在房间里五分钟，你可以选择做更多的谜题，或者你可以拿起一本杂志。在这种情况下，你会拿起杂志，或者今天你会拿出你的手机。另一方面，他研究中的参与者只是被告知，嘿，看看
these puzzles, see if you like them. There was no mention of money. When they were left alone in that room, they kept on trying to do new puzzles. They retained their intrinsic motivation. And this has huge implications for how we get people to do things. Do we try to sort of bribe and coerce them using external rewards? I mean, sometimes that's necessary, but it's also very powerful medicine that can spoil an activity maybe for life for a person. Your child starts to take piano lessons and you increase their allowance when they practice
这些谜题，看看你是否喜欢它们。没有提到钱。当他们被单独留在那个房间里时，他们继续尝试做新的谜题。他们保持了他们的内在动机。这对我们如何让人们做事情有巨大的影响。我们是否试图通过使用外部奖励来贿赂和强迫他们？我的意思是，有时这是必要的，但它也是一种非常强大的药物，可能会毁掉一个人的一项活动，甚至是一辈子。你的孩子开始上钢琴课，你增加了他们练习时的零花钱
a certain amount. That may keep them practicing for a while, but in the long run, they're probably going to lose interest because they've lost touch with the inherently enjoyable part of playing the piano. You conducted a real-world study that had some remarkable findings. You're working, of course, at the University of Missouri, which has a very extensive athletic program. Some student athletes at the school are recruits whose tuition and expenses are paid for by athletic scholarships. Others are walk-ons who play just for the fun of it. So one group has a bunch of external incentives to play. The other primarily has internal incentives. Now you've studied these two groups of athletes and their long-term involvement
一定数量。这可能会让他们练习一段时间，但从长远来看，他们可能会失去兴趣，因为他们已经失去了与弹钢琴本身所带来的乐趣的联系。你进行了一项现实世界的研究，有一些非凡的发现。你当然是在密苏里大学工作，该大学有非常广泛的体育项目。学校里的一些学生运动员是招募来的，他们的学费和费用由体育奖学金支付。其他人是自愿加入的，他们只是为了好玩而参加。所以一组人有一堆外部激励来参加比赛。另一组主要有内部激励。现在你研究了这两组运动员以及他们的长期参与
with an enthusiasm for their sport. What do you find Ken? What we were trying to do was show intrinsic motivation undermining that lasts for decades, not just a few minutes. Right? So DC's early studies showed, you know, in that five-minute period you wouldn't pick up the puzzle. What we wanted to see was during that four-year period of college when you were getting, you were getting everything paid for, did that ruin that sport for the rest of your life? And what we found was that the varsity athletes up to 30, 40 years later were much less interested in playing the sport in the present day or even paying attention to what was happening in the sport, in the
和对他们运动的热情。你发现了什么，肯？我们试图做的是展示内在动机的削弱，这种削弱持续了几十年，而不仅仅是几分钟。对吧？所以迪西的早期研究表明，你知道，在那五分钟里你不会拿起谜题。我们想看的是在大学的那四年里，当你得到报酬，一切费用都由别人支付时，这是否毁了你余生的那项运动？我们发现的是，校队运动员在 30、40 年后对在今天参加这项运动，甚至关注这项运动中正在发生的事情的兴趣要小得多，
colleges or the professional leagues. Whereas the students who only participated as walk-ons originally retained their interest in the sport. I mean, that's such a paradoxical finding, isn't it? Because of course, the students who are the varsity players are being rewarded. They're being told, we love how you play. We're going to give you these incentives to keep playing. It's really strange that these external incentives seem to damage people's internal drive or love for the sport. Yes, it is strange. You would think that they're so good at the sport. They've spent so
在大学或职业联赛中。而最初只是作为自愿者参与的学生保留了他们对这项运动的兴趣。我的意思是，这是一个非常矛盾的发现，不是吗？因为当然，作为校队球员的学生得到了奖励。他们被告知，我们喜欢你的表现。我们要给你这些激励让你继续比赛。这些外部激励似乎损害了人们的内在动力或对运动的热爱，这真的很奇怪。是的，这很奇怪。你会认为他们非常擅长这项运动。他们花了
much time practicing it. They were able to earn a scholarship, they should be the ones who really continue to like it. The reason that they don't comes down to the fact that they felt very controlled during their college years. They felt like they had to do it. They'd lose their scholarship if they didn't. People were talking about them on the discussion boards. The fans were criticizing them. The coaches were bossing them on the discussion boards, the fans were criticizing them, the coaches were
这么多时间练习它。他们能够获得奖学金，他们应该是那些真正继续喜欢它的人。他们不这样做的原因归结为这样一个事实，即他们在大学期间感到非常受控制。他们觉得他们必须这样做。如果他们不这样做，他们就会失去奖学金。人们在讨论版上谈论他们。粉丝们在批评他们。教练们在讨论版上，粉丝们在批评他们，教练们在
bossing them around. And so when people feel controlled by their environment or their situation, that really tends to undermine their intrinsic motivation. And so as soon as it appears that it's okay to stop doing it, they're prone to go ahead and stop. So I want to summarize where we are. You know, if we want to know what to do with our lives, we need to examine our inclinations and propensities. We should try and hold at bay the signals we get from the outside world about what's truly important. But it turns out that doing these things may not be enough.
对他们指手画脚。所以当人们感到被环境或情况控制时，这往往会削弱他们的内在动机。因此，一旦看起来可以停止这样做，他们就倾向于继续并停止。所以我想总结一下我们现在所处的位置。你知道，如果我们想知道如何生活，我们需要审视我们的倾向和习性。我们应该尝试并抑制我们从外部世界得到的关于什么才是真正重要的信号。但事实证明，做这些事情可能还不够。
In some ways, maybe we should go back to the days after you graduated from college. You know, I think you were following your inclinations and propensities when you decided to become a musician. You were not following the dictates of, you know, money and power and status. Some of your research has focused on what may be the trickiest problem of all, which is we fail to understand ourselves because when we look inward, we can only see one aspect of our own minds.
在某些方面，也许我们应该回到你大学毕业后的日子。你知道，我认为当你决定成为一名音乐家时，你是在追随你的倾向和习性。你没有遵循金钱、权力和地位的指令。你的一些研究集中在可能最棘手的问题上，那就是我们无法理解自己，因为当我们向内看时，我们只能看到自己思想的一个方面。
How so so Ken? Yeah I think this might be one of those profound problems that we human beings face. The fact that we are kind of stuck in a psychological world that is sort of a simulation of what's going on underneath. We can only be conscious of a limited amount at any moment. And the things that we think and are conscious of can be very influenced by outside forces and pressures as we've discussed. And so it takes quite a bit of time and work
怎么会这样，肯？是的，我认为这可能是我们人类面临的那些深刻问题之一。事实上，我们被困在一个心理世界中，这是一种对底层正在发生的事情的模拟。我们在任何时刻都只能意识到有限的数量。正如我们所讨论的，我们思考和意识到的事情会受到外部力量和压力的很大影响。所以需要相当多的时间和工作
to figure out what you really want to do. Some of this has to do with the fact that when most of us think about our own minds, we think that our minds are just our conscious minds, but some of your work has looked at the idea that a significant portion of our minds, in fact, are hidden away from conscious introspection. Yeah, there's a large tradition in motivation research and in other areas of psychology that sort of revive the idea of the non-conscious mind, not saying that it's Freud's idea of the place where the nasty stuff is hidden. Instead, it's the place where we have habitual inclinations, emerging intuitions, motives that we kind of go after, maybe even
来弄清楚你真正想做什么。这部分与这样一个事实有关，即当我们大多数人思考自己的思想时，我们认为我们的思想只是我们的意识，但你的一些工作研究了这样一个想法，即我们思想的很大一部分实际上隐藏在意识内省之外。是的，在动机研究和心理学的其他领域有一个庞大的传统，它复兴了非意识思维的想法，不是说它是弗洛伊德关于肮脏东西隐藏的地方的想法。相反，它是我们拥有习惯性倾向、涌现的直觉、动机的地方，我们可能会追求这些，甚至
without our own awareness. And so it's pretty important to learn to hook up the two minds as much as we can to get our conscious selves to accurately reflect what's going on in there at a deeper level. When we come back, how to figure out what's inside, well, your hidden brain. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Ken Sheldon studies how we come up with the goals that animate our lives.
没有我们自己的意识。所以学习尽可能多地连接这两个思想，让我们的意识自我准确地反映那里更深层次正在发生的事情，是非常重要的。当我们回来时，如何弄清楚里面有什么，嗯，你隐藏的大脑。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家肯·谢尔顿研究我们是如何得出那些赋予我们生活活力的目标的。
He's the author of Freely Determined, what the new psychology of the self teaches us about how to live. Ken's research has found that happiness comes when we bring together the propensities and inclinations we are aware of with deeper preferences that lie in our unconscious minds. Ken, you have a name for this process
他是《自由决定：自我心理学新知教我们如何生活》的作者。肯的研究发现，当我们把我们意识到的倾向和习性与潜意识中更深层的偏好结合起来时，幸福就会到来。肯，你有一个名字来称呼这个过程
of successfully matching our goals to our conscious and non-conscious inclinations and propensities? You call this self-concordance. What do you mean by this term? Self-concordance is simultaneously a simple and a complex concept. People pursuing non-concordant goals are often doing something mainly because somebody else wants them to somebody who's important to them. It could be parents, it
成功地将我们的目标与我们的意识和非意识倾向和习性相匹配？你称之为“自我一致性”。你用这个术语是什么意思？自我一致性既是一个简单的概念，也是一个复杂的概念。追求非一致性目标的人通常做某事主要是因为别人希望他们这样做，一个对他们很重要的人。可能是父母，它
could be a spouse. Other times they are trying to be something that they themselves think they should be. They've got this idea maybe that goes way back in their lives of what kind of person they are and what they need to do to be that kind of person. And the problem with both of these types of motivations is it makes it difficult to hear more subtle signals that are coming up from our non-conscious minds that might help us to realize that this isn't quite it yet. So of course the things that are in our minds that are not consciously accessible to us are by definition, you know, not consciously accessible to us. So merely asking ourselves what our non-conscious minds are up to will not give us the answers.
可能是配偶。其他时候，他们试图成为他们自己认为他们应该成为的人。他们可能在生活中很早就有了关于他们是什么样的人以及他们需要做什么才能成为那种人的想法。这两种动机的问题在于，它使我们难以听到来自我们非意识思维的更微妙的信号，这些信号可能帮助我们意识到这还不是完全正确的。所以当然，我们思想中那些我们无法有意识地接触到的东西，根据定义，你知道，是我们无法有意识地接触到的。所以仅仅问自己我们的非意识思维在做什么，是不会给我们答案的。
So your research has found that one way to get at what's happening in our non-conscious minds is to follow a path that artists designers and inventors take as they engage in the process of discovery. What are the steps in this process, Ken? Yeah, this was a very interesting connection that occurred to me at one point because I used to study creativity I was mine dissertation research topic and there's an important idea in creativity theory of the four stages of creativity. You start by asking yourself a question, you don't know the answer, you want the solution to the scientific problem or the new approach to painting that
所以你的研究发现，获取我们非意识思维中正在发生的事情的一种方法是，遵循艺术家、设计师和发明家在参与发现过程时所采取的路径。这个过程的步骤是什么，肯？是的，这是一个非常有趣的联系，我在某一点上想到了它，因为我过去研究创造力，这是我的论文研究主题，创造力理论中有一个关于创造力四个阶段的重要想法。你从问自己一个问题开始，你不知道答案，你想要科学问题的解决方案，或者绘画的新方法，
seems to be in there, something intriguing is calling to you. So you ask yourself this question and you don't know the answer. And so then there needs to be an incubation period where you go and think about something else. What happens is that your non-conscious mind keeps working on the problem while you're thinking about something else, just because you sort of consciously pose that question to yourself. Then you went away and now it's working on it. And so hopefully along comes a moment of inspiration and a-ha moment where some stray thought or
似乎就在那里，有什么吸引人的东西在呼唤你。所以你问自己这个问题，而你不知道答案。所以然后需要一个孵化期，你去思考别的事情。发生的事情是，当你在思考别的事情时，你的非意识思维会继续处理这个问题，仅仅因为你某种程度上在意识上向自己提出了那个问题。然后你走开了，现在它正在处理它。所以希望随之而来的是灵感的时刻，一个顿悟的时刻，一些零散的想法或
idea or image pops up and you recognize, whoa, that's interesting. What's that about? And you start to work with that idea and you realize that it's the solution to the problem. So this is a very common sort of creative sequence. And my idea was that maybe discovering what we really want is a creative activity. And maybe we can self prompt this activity. We don't just have to wait for insights out of the blue. We can consciously ask ourselves question like,
想法或图像突然出现，你意识到，哇，这很有趣。那是关于什么的？你开始处理那个想法，你意识到它是问题的解决方案。所以这是一个非常常见的创造性序列。我的想法是，也许发现我们真正想要什么是一种创造性活动。也许我们可以自我提示这种活动。我们不必只是等待突如其来的洞察。我们可以有意识地问自己问题，比如，
why am I so unhappy? What do I really want? What's bothering me? What's happening inside of me? And when we ask those questions, we don't know the answer right away, but very often we begin to get hints. So, partly what I hear you saying is that this process of preparation is really important. It's important to actually try and grapple with the problem consciously, even if it turns out that
为什么我这么不快乐？我真正想要什么？什么在困扰我？我内心发生了什么？当我们问这些问题时，我们不会马上知道答案，但通常我们开始得到暗示。所以，我听到你说的部分原因是，这个准备过程真的很重要。尝试并有意识地努力解决这个问题很重要，即使结果证明
the answer lies in our non-conscious minds. Because by grappling with something consciously, you're setting the stage, if you will, to have a conversation with your non-conscious minds because by grappling with something consciously, you're setting the stage, if you will, to have a conversation with your non-conscious mind and to allow something to bubble up. That's exactly right. And a colleague and I now are writing a review article where we're trying to make a firm connection between the phenomenology of conscious choice of asking one's mind questions, and neuroscience.
答案在于我们的潜意识。因为通过有意识地去钻研某件事，你实际上是在为与潜意识进行对话做准备，让某些东西浮现出来。完全正确。我和一位同事目前正在撰写一篇综述文章，试图在有意识选择的现象学（即向自己的内心提问）与神经科学之间建立牢固的联系。
You know, what's happening in these brain networks when we do that? And we're finding some really striking points of connection supporting the idea that when we ask ourselves a question, it puts our brains to work in ways that we don't know about, but that can do an amazing job of helping us. So once a period of preparation has led to a moment of illumination, we then have to proceed to the stage you call verification. Is that right? Not every revelation we have will pan out. That's true. Not every aha experience is the best or final aha experience.
你知道，当我们这样做时，大脑网络中发生了什么？我们发现了一些非常引人注目的连接点，支持这样一种观点：当我们向自己提问时，大脑会以我们所不知道的方式开始工作，但这种工作能极好地帮助我们。所以，一旦准备阶段引导我们进入了顿悟时刻，我们就必须进入你所说的验证阶段。是这样吗？并非我们所有的启示都能成功。确实如此。并非每一次“啊哈”时刻都是最好或最终的顿悟。
And so life is an experiment and then we need to test the idea once we become aware of it. And we might realize that, no, we don't want to quit everything and move to Mexico and lay on a beach. That's not really going to be as fulfilling as we think. Let's keep thinking and maybe a better choice will come. In order to know what we really want, we need to get better at attending to subtle thoughts and feelings that many of us have spent lifetimes suppressing. Like many other skills, the ability to listen to yourself can be improved
因此，生活是一场实验，一旦我们意识到某个想法，就需要去验证它。我们可能会意识到，不，我们并不想辞掉一切搬到墨西哥去躺在沙滩上。那实际上并不会像我们想象的那样令人满足。让我们继续思考，也许更好的选择会出现。为了知道我们真正想要什么，我们需要更善于关注许多人一生都在压抑的微妙想法和感受。像许多其他技能一样，倾听自己的能力可以通过刻意练习来提高。
through deliberate practice. Ken says there are techniques that can help. One of them is to use mindfulness meditation where you're just trying to do nothing. You're just being a blank conscious screen and you're trying to watch what pops up and you're trying to stay present and not be sort of sucked away by the next thought or the next fear or emotion. And the usefulness of mindfulness for discovering what you really want is that you're learning how to notice these subtle signals that might be lurking on the fringe of consciousness you might not recognize those until you develop this skill of Really kind of picking up on these
肯说有一些技巧可以提供帮助。其中之一是使用正念冥想，你只是试图什么都不做。你只是作为一个空白的意识屏幕，试图观察浮现出的东西，并试图保持当下，而不被下一个念头、恐惧或情绪所带走。正念对于发现你真正想要的东西的用处在于，你正在学习如何注意到那些可能潜伏在意识边缘的微妙信号，如果你不培养这种技能，你可能无法识别这些微妙的事情。
Subtle things that are happening if you'll just shut up and listen Ken, in your book, Freely Determined, you write about a character you call Amy. She's not a real person, but an amalgamation of many people you've worked with. And you use Amy's story to illustrate your technique of getting to self-concordance. Set things up for me. Who is Amy and what is the challenge she faces? As a college student, Amy was very influenced by a friend who encouraged Amy's interest in the environment and influenced Amy to join groups with her and work for the environment. So that was a big part of Amy's life in college. But then she went to law school and did very well,
如果你只是闭嘴倾听的话。肯，在你的书《自由决定》（Freely Determined）中，你写到了一个你称之为艾米的虚构人物。她不是真实存在的人，而是你共事过的许多人的集合体。你用艾米的故事来说明你达到自我一致性的技巧。请为我铺垫一下。艾米是谁？她面临什么挑战？作为一名大学生，艾米深受一位朋友的影响，这位朋友鼓励了艾米对环境的兴趣，并影响她加入小组并为环境工作。所以那是艾米大学生活中很重要的一部分。但后来她上了法学院，表现非常好，
but she fell prey to this problem I described earlier, that the high-performing law students tend to become sort of corrupted by their success. And she ended up as a wealthy partner, extremely successful by conventional standards, lawyer working in a big firm in a big city, but she was miserable and she had no idea why at that point. One weekend she talked to her brother at a family gathering and his brother asked some difficult questions, well if you're so miserable why are you still doing this? And that caused her to start thinking in the way I've described. It set her unconscious mind into motion.
但她陷入了我之前描述的问题，即高成就的法学院学生往往会被他们的成功所“腐蚀”。她最终成为了一名富有的合伙人，按照传统标准非常成功，在大城市的一家大律所工作，但她很痛苦，而且当时她根本不知道为什么。一个周末，在一次家庭聚会上，她和哥哥谈话，哥哥问了一些尖锐的问题：如果你这么痛苦，为什么还要继续做这份工作？这促使她开始以我描述的方式思考。这让她的潜意识开始运作。
And the first effects of that process was when the thought of the woman that she knew back in college popped into her head one day at work. And it had been 25 years. Why was she thinking of her now? She finally got to a point where she Googled that person, discovered that they ran their own consulting firm for environmental issues. It took a while for Amy to go from this knowledge to saying, well, maybe I'll reach out to her and see, I'll email her and see how she's doing. But when she finally got to that last point, the friend was very glad to hear from Amy, thought that Amy had skills that she needed and invited Amy to come work with her.
这个过程的最初效果是，有一天在工作中，她脑海中突然浮现出大学时认识的那位女性的想法。那已经是25年前的事了。为什么她现在会想起她？她最终查到了那个人的信息，发现对方经营着一家自己的环境问题咨询公司。艾米从得知这个信息到说“也许我会联系她看看，发邮件问问她过得怎么样”，花了一些时间。但当她最终迈出那一步时，朋友很高兴收到艾米的消息，认为艾米拥有她所需要的技能，并邀请艾米来和她一起工作。
And so Amy changed her job. She took a 50% cut in salary. She moved to a different city, 50% cut in salary. She moved to a different city, but she's way happier now than she was before because she has gotten back to those early adult interests in making a difference in the world. So in terms of the specific techniques that you mentioned a second ago, the idea of preparation, illumination and verification, how does Amy's story represent those stages, Ken?
于是艾米换了工作。她接受了50%的减薪。她搬到了另一个城市，虽然减薪了，但她现在比以前快乐多了，因为她找回了成年早期对改变世界的兴趣。那么，就你刚才提到的具体技巧，即准备、顿悟和验证的概念，艾米的故事是如何体现这些阶段的呢，肯？
Nothing happened until she started to ask herself, what's the problem? What do I really want? And then nothing happened after that for quite some time because it was a big problem and it took a while for her non-conscious mind to process it. But then that mind found ways to bring to her attention this relevant image from her past, but she still needed to recognize the aha moment. And then she still needed to elaborate it and follow it through and contact her friend and so forth.
在她开始问自己“问题是什么？我真正想要什么？”之前，什么都没有发生。在那之后很长一段时间里，也什么都没有发生，因为这是一个大问题，她的潜意识需要一段时间来处理。但后来，潜意识找到了方法，将她过去的相关形象带入她的注意中，但她仍然需要识别出那个“啊哈”时刻。然后她还需要将其具体化，付诸行动，联系她的朋友等等。
But the whole sequence fits this model that we've discussed quite well. You know, it's so interesting when you think about it, so few of us actually ask ourselves those big questions. And those of us who do often don't listen to the voice of illumination that might pop up. And then those of us who do often don't listen to the voice of illumination that might pop up. And then those of us who do that might not actually stop to verify or elaborate it. And it really is several different steps, and each of them is actually quite important.
但整个过程非常符合我们讨论的模型。你知道，当你思考这个问题时，这非常有趣，我们中很少有人真正问自己那些重大问题。而那些问了的人，往往不去倾听可能浮现出的顿悟之声。而那些听到了的人，可能实际上并没有停下来去验证或具体化它。这确实是几个不同的步骤，每一个步骤其实都非常重要。
Yes, it is too. They're all important, and the process can be stalled anywhere along the way. One of the biggest problems Amy had was when she had this invitation to join her friend's company was making the cut from her old job because she knew that her old colleagues would see it as a step down, working for so much less, so much less status. And so she needed to muster the courage to go ahead and take the step anyway.
是的，确实如此。它们都很重要，而且这个过程在任何阶段都可能停滞。艾米遇到的最大问题之一是，当她收到加入朋友公司的邀请时，要做出离开旧工作的决定，因为她知道旧同事会认为这是一种倒退，薪水少得多，地位也低得多。所以她需要鼓起勇气，无论如何都要迈出这一步。
One of the subtle traps that you have studied is the idea that once we make choices, our minds are very good at coming up with reasons why those choices are in fact the correct choices. It becomes very difficult to actually evaluate the choice, you know, really on its own merits. Can you talk about that idea that there is a commitment that happens inside our minds once we've decided to go down path A rather than path B? Yes, Peter Gold, sir, in his great research has shown that at some point we cross a rubicon of decision. And what that means is we make up our minds. We're no longer thinking about
你研究过的微妙陷阱之一是，一旦我们做出选择，我们的头脑非常擅长找出理由来证明这些选择确实是正确的。要真正客观地评估这个选择本身变得非常困难。你能谈谈这种想法吗？即一旦我们决定走A路径而不是B路径，我们的头脑中就会产生一种承诺。是的，彼得·戈尔泽在他的伟大研究中表明，在某个时刻，我们跨越了决策的卢比孔河。这意味着我们下定了决心。我们不再思考
what we might want. We've now made a choice, and we're going to go ahead with it. And what his research shows is that once we cross that Rubicon from deliberation to implementation, our minds operate very differently. We're no longer questioning what we're thinking. Instead, we're trying to make plans. We're trying to preserve the goal. We're no longer questioning what we're thinking. Instead, we're trying to make plans. We're trying to preserve the goal. We don't want to wimp out on it. We want to take the next step. We don't want to have to go back to that uncomfortable position of wondering what we want. In some ways, we become almost prosecutors. We're basically amassing evidence for a conclusion that we've already reached instead of having an open mind.
我们可能想要什么。我们已经做出了选择，并且打算继续执行。他的研究表明，一旦我们跨越了从审议到执行的卢比孔河，我们的头脑运作方式就会大不相同。我们不再质疑自己的想法。相反，我们试图制定计划。我们试图维护目标。我们不想在目标上退缩。我们想采取下一步。我们不想回到那种想知道自己想要什么的令人不舒服的状态。在某种程度上，我们几乎变成了检察官。我们基本上是在为已经得出的结论收集证据，而不是保持开放的心态。
That's exactly right. We don't want to think that I chose the wrong thing. That creates dissonance. It's uncomfortable. And so we protect ourselves from that thought. And many times, that's a good thing. We don't want to let ourselves worry too much. We want to get on with things. But sometimes that dissonance can be a valuable signal,
完全正确。我们不想认为自己选错了。这会产生认知失调。这很不舒服。所以我们保护自己免受那种想法的影响。很多时候，这是一件好事。我们不想让自己担心太多。我们想继续前进。但有时这种失调可能是一个有价值的信号，
as we've been talking about with Amy, that can let us know that maybe it is time to go back to the deliberation phase. Once we take the time to really look inward and listen to the quiet voices within us, there is still an important hurdle to overcome. Just because Amy discovered what felt like her true calling, doesn't mean that the rest of her life was going to be a bed of roses. Getting to self-concordance is a great way to harness the power of intrinsic motivation and to start to live your life in accordance with your deepest values.
正如我们一直在谈论艾米时所说的那样，它可以让我们知道，也许是时候回到审议阶段了。一旦我们花时间真正向内看，倾听内心安静的声音，仍然有一个重要的障碍需要克服。仅仅因为艾米发现了她认为的真正使命，并不意味着她余下的生活就会一帆风顺。达到自我一致性是利用内在动机力量并开始按照你最深层的价值观生活的好方法。
But changing course and making plans for a new life are not enough. As boxing heavyweight champion and part-time psychologist Mike Tyson once said, everyone has a plan until they get punched in the mouth. Ken has studied the motivations of people who, in a single season, hike the Pacific Crest Trail. The trail runs more than 2,600 miles from Mexico to Canada. I asked him to share what happens to the hikers' intrinsic motivation as their journey unfolds. Yeah, this was really interesting data.
但改变方向和为新生活制定计划是不够的。正如重量级拳击冠军兼业余心理学家迈克·泰森曾经说过的，每个人都有计划，直到他们被重重地打了一拳。肯研究过那些在一个季节内徒步走完太平洋屋脊步道的人的动机。这条步道从墨西哥到加拿大全长超过2600英里。我请他分享徒步者在旅程展开时，他们的内在动机发生了什么变化。是的，这是非常有趣的数据。
The most dramatic thing that happened was that their intrinsic motivation to do the hike plummeted over the course of the summer. It no longer seemed so interesting and challenging and fun at the end. Instead, it was much more of a kind of a slog for most people who were able to go that far. You found that when intrinsic motivation wanes in this way It can actually be replaced by something else a different reason for pushing forward but one that is still positive It's called identified motivation. What is this Ken? Yeah, identified motivation is the kind where it's not that you're doing it because it's fun and interesting.
最戏剧性的事情是，他们在整个夏天徒步的内在动机急剧下降。到最后，它看起来不再那么有趣、具有挑战性和令人愉快了。相反，对于大多数能走那么远的人来说，这更像是一种苦差事。你发现当内在动机以这种方式减弱时，它实际上可以被其他东西所取代，一种推动前进的不同理由，但仍然是积极的。这被称为“认同动机”。这是什么，肯？是的，认同动机是指那种你做某事不是因为它有趣，
Instead, you're doing it because it's meaningful, it expresses your values, and it's important to you. And so even when intrinsic motivation fails, identified motivation can still keep going because it believes in the journey, even if the journey is now becoming more and more painful. You know it's so interesting a lot of this research I think speaks to the importance of mindfulness or being you know willing to listen and pay attention to where you are and how you might really feel.
而是因为它有意义，它表达了你的价值观，并且对你很重要。所以即使内在动机失败了，认同动机仍然可以让你坚持下去，因为它相信这段旅程，即使旅程现在变得越来越痛苦。你知道这非常有趣，我认为这项研究中的很多内容都说明了正念的重要性，或者说愿意倾听并关注你所处的位置以及你真实的感受。
I'm not quite sure it goes all the way back to that S seminar that you did in your 20s but to some extent some of it is about really paying attention to where you are. It's true and that is something that we all need to know how to do better. It's something that our schools don't teach us, our parents don't teach us. We're self-programming organisms. We are creating our lives via our choices, but we are not taught how to do it well, not taught how to ask ourselves the questions that will get
我不确定这是否能追溯到你20多岁时参加的那个S研讨会，但在某种程度上，其中一些内容确实是关于真正关注你所处的位置。这是真的，这是我们都需要学习如何做得更好的事情。这是我们的学校不教我们的，我们的父母也不教我们的。我们是自我编程的有机体。我们通过选择创造我们的生活，但我们没有被教导如何做好这件事，没有被教导如何问自己那些能得到
us the answers that we need. Psychologist Ken Sheldon works at the University of Missouri. He's the author of Freely Determined, what the new psychology of the self teaches us about how to live. Ken, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, and thank you for inviting me. I've had a great time. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
我们需要答案的问题。心理学家肯·谢尔顿在密苏里大学工作。他是《自由决定：新自我心理学教我们如何生活》一书的作者。肯，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”节目。谢谢你，也谢谢你邀请我。我度过了一段美好的时光。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑媒体”制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。
This is a particularly good time to give our podcast subscription a try. We're extending our standard seven-day trial period for listeners on Apple podcasts. Sign up in January, and you'll get 30 free days to try it out. You can sample Hidden Brain Plus by going to
现在是尝试我们播客订阅的特别好时机。我们正在为Apple Podcasts的听众延长标准的七天试用期。在一月份注册，你将获得30天的免费试用期。你可以通过访问以下网址来体验“隐藏的大脑Plus”：
apple.co. slash hiddenbrain and clicking Try Free. Again, just go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain and click Try Free. If you've missed any of the episodes in our Wellness 2.0 series, you can find them in this podcast feed or at hiddenbrain.org. Last week we looked at the traits of leaders who keep their cool during moments of crisis. And in our kickoff episode, we explored authenticity and what it means to be true to yourself.
apple.co/hiddenbrain 并点击“免费试用”。再次强调，只需访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain 并点击“免费试用”。如果你错过了我们“健康2.0”系列中的任何一集，你可以在这个播客订阅源或 hiddenbrain.org 上找到它们。上周我们探讨了在危机时刻保持冷静的领导者的特质。在我们的开篇集里，我们探讨了真实性以及忠于自我的意义。
Next week, we continue our series with a conversation about how to avoid despair and burnout when the world around us feels like a train going off the rails. This kind of surrendering of the ego, the surrendering that you can be the savior that saves everything, actually gives you permission to not be terribly effective all the time. Gives you permission to find pleasure in the work. Gives you permission to rest if you need to. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. gives you permission to rest if you need to. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周，我们将继续我们的系列节目，讨论当周围的世界感觉像一列脱轨的火车时，如何避免绝望和倦怠。这种对自我的放弃，放弃认为自己可以成为拯救一切的救世主，实际上给了你一种许可，让你不必一直表现得非常高效。给了你一种许可，让你在工作中找到乐趣。给了你一种许可，让你在需要时休息。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。